abone ol
Herkese
merhaba ben seni tanıtabilir içinden
Zeynep Bugün size ve değerli kabilem ve
kazanma yapmış olduğum olduğundan
bahsetmek istiyorum Bunun için birlikte
espri yapmadım
la
lay lay gördüğünüz gibi ben erkeklerle
kuzenlerim aldım kişilere karşı
karşıya dediğimiz bu duygunun kermes
etmiyor bu sayfanın varlığına yaz
rekabetçi yırtıcı ve biraz da
[Müzik]
Ne
yapmış bu oluyor diye ben seni gördüm
ben Yani anlayacağınız bugün salon için
her şeyi yaparım derken çıka yapıyoruz 7
8 yaşındayken de şu kenardaki Kuzey
düştü ve birlikte her gün
sokaklarda
Toprak yollarda bu
bu yetiştim ama onlar yaşamış
kaybolmuştu yalnız kalmıştım ve
korkmuştum
havada başlamıştım O yüzden Tabii ki de
evliyim ama onları bundan sonra önemli
hale gelmişti ya nice ağzı
buraya giriyorum falan gibi
vardığımda o
[Müzik]
ve bu erkek aile fertlerinin için var mı
hareket başarılı şekilde önce erken mi
Evet o
[Müzik]
o kadar özgüvenleri
benim için o zaman zevki seksi eğlenceli
rahat erkeklerle ilgili anlaşma sağlayan
Hayırdır yapmayan asla altı karşı
olmayan alt Büyük Macera Perez Her yeni
dediğine Evet yeni erkekler birlikte
oturup futbol izleyip şekilde incecik
alabilen mutlu
aslan
erkeklerin tercih ettiği da
ama ben fazla geldiniz
Ben bu kadın var ya çıkmış Gerçekten bu
kadın olduğunu düşünüyordum ve tanımları
dışarı çıkmama izin
vermiyor diğer bütün
parçalarını bölgede o
[Müzik]
O
değil de benim olay veya buna benzer
başka olaylar hakkında duygu ve
düşüncelerini konuşmasına ve bu
anlaşılmıştır Biz karşı tarafın bu
Anlaşması Ben kalıp açmadı Ben bunları
konuşuyoruz Yani anlayacağınız gibi
acılar bitiyordu
de farklı değildi
acılarımı anlamlandırmak için masallar
masallar
oluyor ve o
bir
kahramanın hiçbir doktorumuz alışır
gerçek hayatta daha tuzaklar ve
olabiliyor aşırı yazınızı yapmış olduğum
kötülükler birazdan arsinden gelmeniz
gereken huzursuz olaylar tuzaklar
olabilir ama bence
kendisini yapmış olduğu düşünceler
kendimizi kırdığımız çağlardan ol
[Müzik]
Oy
kurban böyle yazmak çok kolay
arakadaşlar ama
bunun bir sorumlusu Ve ben kendimi
erkeğe beğendiğiniz için
erkek bakış açısıyla sevmeyen
yazmıştım ve o
[Müzik]
o
zaten bu kadınlar aşmaya başladım
yetişir yapılmaya başlanmıştı kişilik
almaya başladım bu hesapladığımız hisler
tamamen tabak vermeye başladı ve öğretim
ve
eğitim ve hayır
hayır ya
[Müzik]
değil mi yendi vardır
bu
işte
inanırız Tamam Zeynep mide güvercinleri
problemleri diye bana gelmesi ya da
nereden tatlı sevgilim İyi güzel kız
arkadaşım denetlemesi zor bilimle bulmak
çok zor
öğretimde biçim Çünkü ben yandım
sorgulamayı öğrendim Aslında
kendimi isteklerini ve
düşüncelerini
benim miydi yoksa
ben
fark ettim ki Aslında o
bu hayatın ki bağımsız arkadaşlarımıza
da ve ve aileniz Kadınlarda da işler
indirilmiş nüfuslu onların kıymetini
anladım ve kadının konuşmak futbolcusunu
konuşmak kendini tanımasını ve büyüğünü
konuşmak benim için dönüştü hep yapmış
olduğum Server tanıtımı malıyla olarak
alın çemberleri uygun kendime ve hayat
sonunda olan bilgi verdi ve YouTube'da
Ben ortaklarım var
[Müzik]
o kadın aldı işte bunu sadece buz olarak
yaptik ve kızım kıralım eski kadın
kadına değiştiğini
çekildikleri Neden Çünkü
biz konuşmacılardan
çok daha büyük bir şeydi Bir kabile
halinde kadın Ama sevgi saygı vardı bir
şey vardı
dertlerini dinlemek vardır kardeş vardı
bir de herhangi videomuza terbiyesiz
saygısız ediyorum yazmam ki bunu da
gerçekten çok oluyor böyle bir durumda
ilk savunmasız kanıyla oldu vermeden
cevabı vermişti bile ya da oradan
parçamı paylaştığım zaman yani her şey
kalktığın zaman evine onu aldıran bir ve
eğlence fareden kapıyı oldum ve kıvranan
gücünün çıplak lıes müziğinde aynı anda
tam yedi dönüştüğünü Ben bu şekilde
deneyimledim şimdi paylaştı o zaman
paylaşabileceğimiz düşünüyorum benim
için bunları Hani bir şeyi de konuşmaz
oldum zaten internette Yer Ver kadına
bunları konuşmakta çok zorlanıyoruz ama
konuşup
paylaşım geldi Çünkü benim deneyimi
Benim yarın başka versiyonu Ayşe Fatma
Deniz aynı Irmak yaşıyoruz Şimdi aslında
yanlarımız ortak hastane iyiyiz Ben
yarın paylaştığım zaman emin olun mesaj
güzelce mesaj geliyordu şimdi ben bunu
yaşadım ben de haber ver şeyler geçiyor
ya da şu anda farkettiğiniz gibi
izlediğiniz zaman senin yüzünden fark
ediyorum ki ben bunu yaşıyorum şu anda
sizinle biliyorum ne yaşadığımı Bunlar
çok değerli Evet
çok benzer ihtiyaçlarımızı ortak
bir hikaye erkek bakış açısıyla ve iyi
değilim varsayımını beynim yoruldu ama
kabul edelim başka bir kadın için silme
her ayıkladım her çocuksu daha sarılmayı
bakmaya ihtiyaç duyuyor ve Belkide daha
bir ricam var abi dengesi şaşmış ı
kendine özgü geçtiğimizi şeyler yapıyor
Karşısındaki insan için
Çünkü karşısındaki insanın istediği
Sevgi hobi bu
nokta şu
Kendimize karşı tarafın istediğini
zannettiğimiz Ama
[Müzik]
bu sadece yapmıyoruz
tek
başına verdiğin için farklı farklı
oluyoruz pişirdi o zaman kaç tane
geliyor iş başında profesyonel ortamda
kendimiz başarılı olan kendisi
pişirdiğimiz nasıl yer var
arabalarımızı
86 kendinizi sıçtığımız
sonra
oluyor bu
uyumu arkadaşlar başarılı öğrenci
bitmez
diyebilirim ki
[Müzik]
bu gereken bunu kendi yapıp kadın olmayı
yere eğlendiğimiz olmayayım ama onun şey
olmaz ama başlıyorum
gözüm olması lazım bütün
bütün rollerinize Her halimize bütün mı
[Müzik]
da karşılaşacaksınız Bazı insanlar
sadece sağlamak için sağlayacak
eleştirmek için eleştiriler işimizden
bulacaklar paranızı istedilerse aşağı
çekmek isteyecekler bere Elalem ne der
Suzan'a
kalmayın yorumlara asla asla üstüne
gitmeyin zaten insanın düşüncesini
söylemesi neden ayrı düşünüyorsunuz onun
yere istiyorsunuz
zincirlerimizi nedir unutma
benim fikrim artık çok daha farklı o
[Müzik]
ama bazen sanırım çok iyi tanıyorum
eğitimi Hayır mı acıktı bekle
kullanıyorum Ama sanırım seçiyorum
Farketmez çünkü gerçekten olmuş
sanmıyorum
ya Ben özgürüm de her an değişim
oluyorum teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]